sur la ligne de départ 15 contenant
isotherme pour la boîte à lunch des
enfants dont les prix varient énormément
allant de 4 à 54 dollars
qui remportera la course pour juger
cette compétition notre collaborateur de
longue date daniel marcelin
le contingent terme à la balle c'est
conçu pour berthe et de la nourriture
naturellement mais toujours à une
température qui est convenable pour la
consommation donc sont même source le
matin on espère la marge du show de
musique c'est en 1904 que le thermos a
été breveté est commercialisé
autrefois avec une double paroi en verre
la plupart de ces contenants sont
maintenant en acier inoxydable
de matériaux durables matériaux solides
et pour conserver la chaleur c'est
simple suffit d'avoir deux contenants
leur dans l'autre avec un matériau
isolant anthony de neuville c'est mon
matériau bones est comme ça isola donc
c'est à dire que la chaleur peut pas
transférer par contact maintenir la
chaleur voilà l'épreuve ultime
[Musique]
les conteuses ou terme ont été soumis
aux mêmes protocoles dont chaque
compagnie long terme au même moment a
été rempli à sa capacité avec la même
soupe qui est à la même température et
on a mesuré quelques heures après ce
serait près à quelle température était
réduite
le premier consul j'ai fait c'est que
les températures de préservation
annoncées ont rarement été respectée à
l'expérimentation on s'apercevait que le
cisr ou le 8 heures promis seront des
pauvres vraiment le sur le test mon
évaluation était basée sur le fait qu'
on devait pas de salins température
beaucoup en bois 60 degrés si pour vous
commandez parce qu'à partir de 60 on
vendre la plage où les populations
bactériennes commencé dirais que sous
les 45 ça commence est vraiment
problématique
j'en ai un qui est carrément échoué le
test est mis à l'intérieur de soi à 93
gré après trois ans il était déjà comme
ça 31 donc vraiment dans la plage la
plus dangereuse pour les libertés
c'est le seul dans le vé de pointe
utilisées pour faire la barre et
athermique donc quand les deux paroisses
et mal et là c'est un coach qui
est dans la course il n'a pas fait mieux
quand est-ce qu'on attend tous avec
celui là hier était pas de couler sur
moi et des fois il revenait sur les
personnes qui étaient à côté de moi
notre experts ne recommandent pas les
modèles avec bâle amovible car ils
maintiennent moins bien la température
de leurs contenus
il déconseille aussi l'achat des
contenants avec large couvercle il faut
comprendre que si le but visé c'est de
faire ouvrir par un enfant c'est ce que
puni ego plus en plus difficile la
fabrique ça aussi c'est un piège à
éviter je passe et saint quentin ce
terme qui permet vous un bon format pour
une boîte à chaussures secondes et comme
le couvert et large c'est une grande
surface par rapport à ce qu'on peut
mettre de dengue par où la chaleur peut
cvq qui prise au terme vraiment près de
ou trois heures c de la température
c'était déjà trop réduite pour la
consommation
druide nous offre un modèle plutôt
ergonomique
la prise est bonne on a mis l'enfant sur
la prison a mis l'emphase sur le design
qui est quand même assez agréable la
difficulté que j'ai eue avec ces
contenants dos et de l'ouvrir une fois
qu'ils étaient sous pression une fois
qu'on a mis liquide chaud de la
cour gains pour lourd et ça demande un
enfant qui est espéré à celui des aux
pompes
il faut aussi surveiller ce qui se cache
dans le couvercle si vous êtes capable
d'enlever facilement et pour la nettoyer
la garde on se répartit aussi primordial
ça doit être nettoyée à toutes les
utilisations
si difficile à nettoyer mon sens c'est
vers quoi l'on parle
daniel recommande un nettoyage à la main
même si le fabricant mentionne que son
produit peut aller au lave-vaisselle la
durée de vie du produit en sera accrue
au fil d'arrivée l'usure gagne sur le
podium les deux contenants francs la
meilleure performance 1 de marc thermos
et celui le choix du président
ça c'est assez surprenant et pour jeudi
parce que lui prochain
réservations température et termine
deuxième découverte très facile à ouvrir
très facile à nettoyer pour un budget
vieux peu plus restreint de cet
excellent
avec un bol donc des jalons et isolation
supérieure qui présent fourni une
station pas si facile à ouvrir mais
quand même qui joue c'est
un des meilleurs sur le plan d'un
présentation températion lui c'est un
très bon achat un peu dispendieux
le meilleur rapport qualité prix revient
aux modalités qui offre malgré son petit
prix des résultats de conservation très
acceptable
finalement le coup de coeur de notre
expert ce duo de la marque geo je
trouvais qu'elle rapporte qu'elle était
prêté nos dans sa constitution fournie
en mode qui offre une isolation
thermique ce pays simplement parce que
le bonne foi de fermer créé une paroi
supplémentaires facile à ouvrir et on en
vendra la haute pression donc lorsqu'il
chaud
pour renforcer pour n'ouvrir nationaux
aura la pression puis vont s'ouvrir
facilement
alors à vos marques prêts bon appétit
[Musique]